Film Courage: How many submissions has Hollyshorts
received each of the past five years?
Daniel Sol, Co-Founder of the Hollyshorts
Film Festival: So five years ago we were at
around 2,000 or so submissions for that year.
This past year we received 5,000 or so submissions
so in-between that we’ve gone from 2,000
to 5,000 for the last 5 years increased around
500 or so for each of those years.
So 2,000, 2,500, 3,000, 3,500, so on and so
forth.
To now last year we’re at 5,000 submissions
for the 14th year.
This is our 15th year coming up and we’re
expecting potentially 6,000 submissions.
That’s a big increase and we might jump
up a thousand this year based on averages.
Of course, early-bird deadline is coming up
next Friday so we’re estimating where it
could be so we’ve seen a big jump these
last five years definitely.
Film Courage: Very cool.
Of those multi-thousand plus films that you’ve
received since the inception of Hollyshorts
how many would you say you’ve personally
watched?
Daniel: A lot.
I say it used to be 100 %, now it’s not
as possible with amount of films and a lot
of family and new duties and things on top
of that.
It’s probably a good at least 80% of all
films.
Film Courage: Wow.
Daniel: If not even more.
The last few years we’ve grown a review
team where I’m overseeing the process more
now and watching certain scores and rewatching
some films and watching my own but I’m not
just hands down watching everything like it
was before say five years ago where I was
literally hunkered down watching every single
film.
2,000 films is much easier than watching five
to six thousands naturally just time permitting
right?
So I’d say that’s probably a healthy and
safe number because I like to see everything.
As much as I can possibly do.
It’s a personal sense of pride and also
maybe I am too controlling?
I don’t know.
Film Courage: Well your name is on it so sure.
Daniel: I’m not sure I just want to watch
all the films.
So there’s that part of it and in the end
films that I am watching or other people are
watching and reviewing the scores, I’m going
to program the films.
I program the festival.
So in the end the films that do get in I’m
watching all of them.
So of that number you asked if you look at
the number of the films that are accepted
or in the festival those I watch 100% of.
So naturally yes I’m going to review scores
of other judges and say okay I want to watch
these, these and these and I’m going to
make sure and let’s see what they are talking
about here and kind of just double check their
work and if I like the films then I can sort
of make that sort of passive approval I’ll
be the one to program the film so I’m sort
of the last go around if it gets in or not
kind of thing.
Film Courage: I’m curious about this review
team.
How are they and how do you screen them to
know they are really indie film fans.
Daniel: Well we do a process of giving the
a soft start right?
Okay hey this is our criteria, this is what
we look for, we have a very big breakdown,
very thorough breakdown of how we judge, what
we score, what we’re looking for, what the
process is, understanding how many films come
in because if you just watch films for for
the film.
If you’re just watching a film, you might
like a film and you think it’s okay and
there’s elements you like and there are
elements you don’t like but you’re like
okay this has a chance, you might score a
little lenient or something not understanding
that there are 6,000 submissions and there
are only 400 spots that actually can get in
so that number is what?
5 to 8% can actually make the festival, it’s
very competitive.
So if you’re looking at it from that standpoint
and only watch five to ten films they may
not understand the full scope of how many
films are there, does that make sense?
There’s a lot of films to watch.
So if they’re just looking at their batch,
they may not understand the full scope so
we try to break down a very thorough listed
out email of what we’re looking for, what
the scope of how many films we receive, what
kind of films we have received, looking at
the line-ups from the years past (we share
the line-ups), hey look at these, review our
schedule so you understand what we’ve show,
the genres, styles different things so they
understand when they are looking at the films
okay what is the full scope of how the festival
programs and what we’ve had before and what
we’re looking for and things like that.
So we give them all that and again assign
only a few films to start if we love their
results and then feel it’s on par with what
we’re looking for then we’ll keep them
on board to review many more films and oversee
the process.
If it is too…it’s usually too lenient
is more troubling for me personally honestly.
It is a very competitive festival and we don’t
want someone who every film is just obviously
“home run and it’s amazing.”
And you watch the film and it’s not on par.
That’s not what we’re looking for.
Now at the same time if you are too harsh…you
know something could be a fantastic film and
they’re grading it like a three out of ten
and it’s like “Okay, you’re being unreasonable.”
So there are both sides and you don’t want
that.
If that’s the case, sometimes we let them
know “Hey, we’re just moving on.”
Or some people we just quite honestly move
on and don’t respond anymore, like we’re
going in another direction we just look for
other people and things like that.
But yes, that’s basically the process.
If you like what there early work is with
a few films we can keep them on for more.
Film Courage: Of the people that you know
in the film industry, is there anyone who
has watched as many short films as you have?
Daniel: I don’t know?
I would say probably no.
I think at this time now we talked about this
years ago I would say “Who knows?
I don’t know.”
I think it’s safe to say when you look at
the math of all the films over all this many
years and since we’re essentially just shorts
only and not features, I think we’ve probably
watched as many shorts as anyone in the world
I guess?
It’s a lot of movies we’ve watched!
So I start thinking like “Yes, have I watched
more shorts than anyone?”
I don’t know it sounds weird to say but
it’s possible.
It’s a lot of films.
I mean you’re talking at least…I don’t
know say on 15 years averages 2,500 films
say?
What is that number?
30,000 movies or something?
I don’t know, it’s a lot of movies so
we’ve seen a lot of shorts.